on my way to the grocery store mentally
preparing myself
for the sticker shock
here we are wish me luck
got my diapers it might be something
else for you for me it's diapers is
really where like I notice inflation the
most one of the things that's
interesting about this particular period
of inflation that we're in is this is a
worldwide phenomenon hi books my
question is about inflation what is that
if cause is it just kovid or we have
other stupid
diapers in the U.S food in Ghana and
home prices in India what actually
caused all this inflation and is there
something we can do about it
[Music]
yes
if you watch cable news in the US you
will see one explanation for inflation
that gets a lot of attention there's
still too much money
too much money chasing too few goods say
I have a car dealership say we're in a
global pandemic factories are shutting
down periodically and I'm just not able
to keep as many cars on my lot my
inventory is low but at the same time I
have customers willing to spend money on
my cars my inventory starts to dwindle
and now there's more customers than
there are cars so I can just increase
the price too much money chasing too few
goods economists like this guy Larry
Summers he's been sounding the alarm
Bell about this kind of inflation from
the beginning I am much more worried
that we'll have inflation this is a
least responsible macroeconomic policies
we had in the last 40 years he is
talking about those pandemic relief
checks before we can figure out if Larry
Summers is right we need to take a
closer look at exactly how inflation is
measured in the first place once a month
the U.S Bureau of Labor Statistics puts
together what it calls a Market Basket
these data are specific to the US but
you can find similar numbers around the
world the BLS looks at the prices for
different goods and services like
housing electricity apparel prescription
drugs Bakery products dairy they look at
the price we're paying this month and
then compare it to the price for the
same good or service last month or last
year then they calculate a single
percentage that captures all of that
change and that's the Consumer Price
Index or CPI
and it's true the Consumer Price Index
has been rising steadily for the past
couple of years here's when those
stimulus checks went out but now let's
take a closer look at some of the
specific goods and services that make up
the CPI some things are way more
expensive than this time last year like
fuel oil airline fares gas baked goods
dairy products but there is some stuff
that's held fairly steady in a normal
healthy economy the Federal Reserve
expects for inflation to be about two
percent a year and for stuff like
clothing prescription drugs and
education prices are only slightly above
that two percent mark for used cars and
trucks gasoline and communication that's
your phone plan internet streaming
prices are actually lower than this time
last year it seems a bit more
complicated than simply people have too
much money if that were the only problem
wouldn't everything be more expensive
[Music]
so unfortunately for me the Bureau of
Labor Statistics doesn't actually track
the price of diapers as part of the CPI
but I did find a private research firm
Nielsen IQ that does so Nielsen looks at
something called the unit price
basically they take the box of diapers
divide it by how many diapers are in the
box and that gives you the unit price
they get a bunch of different brands and
then come up with this average so in
2019 the average unit price for diapers
was 16.1 cents if prices had gone up at
that expected two percent annual
inflation rate January of 2023 would
have seen me paying 17.4 cents per
diaper
but of course that's not what the last
few years have looked like if the price
of diapers had increased at the same
rate as the CPI I would be paying 19
cents per diaper in January of 2023 but
no no no no I am currently paying 21
cents per diaper an increase of over 30
percent
so why is it that the price of diapers
is rising so much faster than the price
of all these other Goods you can think
of the cost of a business in a couple of
ways right there's the wages that you
pay for workers there are investments in
capital in the Machinery itself and all
of that adds up to the cost of
production and then there's the cost
that you actually sell the good at and
the difference between those two costs
are called a markup one of the things
that makes it difficult to report on
inflation is that reporters and
consumers we don't know how much it
costs companies to pay their workers we
don't know how much it costs them to
import the materials that they need
but we can guess take labor costs for
example we know that from 2019 to 2023
the average hourly wage for someone
working in manufacturing Rose by about
17 percent now that is faster than what
you would expect under normal two
percent annual inflation but when you
consider the fact that corporations have
successfully kept wages so low in the
Years leading up to that point that they
were actually declining relative to
inflation this recent bump starts to
look more like a kind of return to
normalcy okay but what about the cost of
materials I went to the Pampers website
and looked at what goes into making a
diaper it turns out this stuff is made
out of wood and these are all Plastics
which are made by refining Petroleum in
slightly different ways according to the
federal reserve's producer price index
the average price for both of these
materials wood pulp and Plastic Products
has risen significantly over the past
five years but both of these Rising
input costs still don't completely
explain the price hike in diapers
foreign
S I really wanted to talk to rakeen is
that she and her colleagues have
listened to hundreds and hundreds of
hours of earnings calls what we found is
Big corporations who are jacking up
prices beyond what their production
costs would justify these are some
transcripts of those earnings calls that
raquin and her colleagues have been
listening to the CEO of Hostess Brands
for example says of these price hikes
consumers get used to it when all prices
go up it helps a Tyson Foods executive
claimed that price increases for beef
more than offset the higher costs
Visa CEO says that historically
inflation has been a positive for us all
three of these corporations experienced
record profits over the past three years
but what they did with those profits is
instructive they paid that money out to
their shareholders and raised prices for
the rest of us so we have our three
theories for this current moment of
inflation too much money floating around
Supply shocks and massive markups
unfortunately it's probably going to be
months or maybe even years before we
have all of the data necessary to figure
out which one of these three
explanations holds the most weight but
there are still things we can do to help
bring prices down
and we think that inflation in a really
singular way I think that really limits
the vast panoplay of tools that we
actually have to fight this problem
let's start with the tool that the
Federal Reserve has already busted out
raising interest rates
the way that works is it makes it more
expensive for companies to borrow money
which makes it harder for them to invest
in new projects and hire new people so
far the FED has raised interest rates
eight times and the unemployment rate
has stayed pretty low but that could
change If the Fed keeps raising rates
the last time inflation got super high
back in the early 80s the FED did huge
interest rate hikes and inflation did go
down but look what happened to
unemployment it shot way up by 1982 one
in 10 people were out of work in the
last month of 2022 prices were starting
to come down in some key areas Dairy
fruits and veggies airline fares prices
for these two items gasoline and fuel
oil are way down and the reason likely
has very little to do with raising
interest rates over the past 12 months
President Biden released millions of
barrels of oil from the U.S emergency
stockpile which increased Global Supply
and drove down the price there's
precedent for doing this in other areas
of the economy in 1939 U.S President
Franklin Roosevelt asked congressman
nearly 900 million dollars to help the
airline industry quadruple their output
[Music]
something Rakim told me about diapers
got me thinking about a third way we
might start bringing prices down turns
out that somewhere between 70 and 80
percent of all the diapers produced in
the U.S are made by two companies this
honestly threw me a little bit but then
I went back and looked at some of that
footage that I shot in the grocery store
gloves Pampers ninjamas those are all
made by Procter and Gamble Huggies
Pull-Ups good nights all made by
Kimberly Clark so while it looks like
parents have a lot of choices in the
diaper aisle we actually don't pasta
makers have allowed really rampant
deregulation that has facilitated these
companies having so much power in a way
that they can back up prices without any
cost to them that Supply style and that
corporate power dial we've let them get
Dusty
we do not and we never did have to throw
workers under the bus in order to bring
down prices
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign